for four years the only words the media
knew were trump and russia
the president is a russian operative
this cloud about collusion with russia
will hang over him no matter where he
stands it does look like he's listening
to putin more than he is american
intelligence we're about to find out if
the new president of our country is
going to do what russia wants the
presidency is effectively a russian op
of course that was all bol and if you
needed any more proof just look at what
russia did before and after trump took
office they took crimea under obama and
they're invading again now that biden's
in the white house
but i'm confused wasn't joe biden
supposed to be the adult in the room the
strong leader with decades of foreign
policy experience
wasn't he the guy that would clean
putin's clock and hold him in check
biden spent a month doing everything he
could to stop putin from invading
and putin invades anyway
but the media
has found the true bad guy in all of
this
and i think you know who it is
why didn't putin do this during the
trump administration because he thought
trump was weakening ukraine especially
on these grounds so this the problem of
ukraine being unfortified goes back
several years and and
much of the fault lies in the trump
administration just to go back to the
trump years because that's when ukraine
became so politicized there was one call
in particular that the so-called perfect
call that trump had
with
you know zielinski
which
you know certainly telegraphed to the
kremlin they could do what they wanted
with ukraine did america would not stand
up
so
why are we listening to these people
joining me now co-host of fox and
friends weekend
pete hegg said all right pete it's clear
the russia hoax is officially dead
that that doesn't fly here now but they
they're confused because the media wants
war
they like war especially a war in europe
they think they can be tough they're
obsessed with nato they
fantasize and fetishize data
but they want to blame this war which
they want
on trump
i've never seen the media so confused
about what to say have you
yeah no i haven't they they want to talk
about the war you're right they do
fetishize it it's something they want to
cover wall-to-wall because it means they
don't have to cover the disaster of the
domestic side of joe biden's presidency
not to mention afghanistan yeah and when
you look ultimate i'm a simple guy on
stuff like this so you laid it out in
2014 that was obama that was crimea now
it's 2022 and now it's eastern ukraine
and that's
biden it was 2018 and 2017 when donald
trump said uh you shouldn't do this
whole nordstrom 2 thing like not a
really good idea that you'd be dependent
on russian oil because vladimir putin
like he's going to use that as leverage
and then they go ahead and kill the
keystone xl pipeline and approved the
very pipeline that makes europe more
vulnerable here's the reality
the the vladimir putin lives rent free
in the minds of our media of the
american media no no organism no entity
has done more to spread russian
propaganda and to prop up the straw man
that is vladimir putin than our very own
media and donald trump was happy to
troll them on it as he continues to do
to this moment because they can't resist
it and they'll obsess over it but when
they they know at the end of the day
when you look at the facts you know you
know remember cnn like to talk about an
apple as an apple if you look at the
facts the reality is under the weakness
of obama and biden vladimir putin took
advantage and he saw a peer in donald
trump who was unpredictable and willing
to defend american interests and he
backed away from that all right we're
not blaming the american
presidents for putin doing what he does
putin does what he does but
it's stupid to blame donald trump when
he's the only president not overseas
default setting a russian invasion of
another country there all right pistol
pete thanks as always
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else